we're beginning guys Quentin Tarantino
is not racist I'm Gregg elbow what's
your name I'm Kyle either man Kyle
either men from fan theory TV go check
out his YouTube channel got a whole
bunch of reactors reacting to a bunch of
stuff him himself included it's a great
time more importantly he's one of my
closest friends so you better go show
them support thanks man
you like Quentin Tarantino yeah we're
gonna watch from honest trailers friends
over at screen junks every Quentin
Tarantino movie have you ever seen the
honest trailers for these breakdowns of
directors work like every sin burger
movie yes not not for Quentin Tarantino
but yes obviously not or else we
wouldn't be filming this right now
wouldn't make a liar out of me this is
the top of war to your request from a
man named Peter Dunne let's watch this
[Music]
deep from the heart of a grindhouse
theater one filmmaker will rise from
video store clerk to the guy video store
clerks house it's so much fun tasty
burger sure when my death proof sure was
[Laughter]
the stage plays
you know
[Music]
music music a third of what's upon a
time where someone is not who they say
they are one of them oh yeah man the
standoffs
[Laughter]
[Music]
history to check the cooler shots from
old movies for himself
Oh Marsha yes as Lucas will be ta we've
got Ritchie or all of us so salute of
living legend who made some of the best
films of a generation yeah like where
the gun yeah oh god there's a real
compilation this
[Laughter]
yes Oh God oh my god
[Music]
[Laughter]
Deathproof opening credit says yeah
[Music]
ah
this is ridiculous
[Laughter]
[Music]
Hey
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
please say monologuing who we say
monologue oh cool awesome episode CSI
phone are mistaken
[Music]
I love what they do here all the writers
for honest trailers especially for these
it's kind of like a funny film analysis
of filmmakers career what they do so
well because they'll point out things
that I have definitely noticed before
but a lot of times are the things I I
didn't really catch on so before I go
into any of those wanted to say the
editors on this episode did a amazing
like this was wonderfully edited
especially at the end when they took the
time to make up look for everything good
yeah good graphics you guys put together
so proud of all you guys pointing out
the thing about the food that is so true
they're always eating food in his movies
it seems like such a month like the foot
fetish thing calls a lot of attention I
love the song they did for that ever the
which by the way can I turn to you I
just saw them performing live one day
and it was like I got to put you guys in
Kill Bill that's like not as it's funny
how that song has become unanimous with
Kill Bill and like part of like the
Tarantino songs that's not it at all he
just featured it in Kill Bill but it
just became defined there same thing
with a lot of the other songs that yeah
I'm not that yours I mean a lot of his
[__] though is it's always just pulled
out from wherever he's experienced
something the only thing I know about
him is he doesn't like to use technology
to record things so he EMS it's be
obvious it's true he prefers film more
than anything else the foot fetish thing
is
draws a lot of attention I feel stupid
that I just didn't notice this about
really I don't know that's always been
like the thing I heard about aren t I
didn't realize it was this intense I
think I like knew in my head but it just
didn't like dawn on me how incredibly
often it is in this film how obsessed he
is with feet yeah
oh really quick as I had my mind just
flashed in the moment Kurt Russell was
looking at persons yeah the death Proof
thing of not counting that as like a
full movie I know they were just like
making a joke here by the way John
Bailey great job on the voice-over acts
on death Proof I agree as part of
grindhouse that is not a complete movie
those are two movies they put it
together to make the grindhouse picture
yeah but most people because Grant House
greatly underperformed at the box office
most people have seen death Proof the
full version you could just buy the DVD
or blu-ray or grind of death Proof and
it's significantly longer and has scenes
in it that make it a full-length feature
film when you don't make it a companion
piece to to the grindhouse yeah that a
lot better
they condensed it originally with a
released crying house because it was two
films back to back with Robert Rodriguez
Tarantino and so once they released it
on DVD and any other form yeah that's
true yeah they separated them I actually
haven't seen the full length version of
kurková
that's death Proof oh really mm-hmm oh
well it has s in that black and white
saying that they had where Kurt Russell
was looking that girl's foot you know go
Ryan house when he's trying to get the
lap dance her Russell mhm stuntman Mike
the grindhouse version it's like lost
film real or something like that as a
joke but in the death Proof version you
see the whole dance yeah it's a sexy
dance
I think I'm part of the Kratz a clip of
monologuing because he usually has a
character in one of his movies that has
like a killer monologue there's always
at least one kid like you know bill and
Kill Bill Vol to several characters in
Kill Bill Christoph Waltz inand glorious
bastards monologues baby because the
characters something they'll still cut
in with someone else asking a question
or throwing in a little bit of dialogue
but so like how they said the thing
about like bringing back actors whatever
the credit joke was you know helping
resurrect actors careers he really did
do that for Pam Grier robber forced or
Bolton yeah he has mass respect for the
industry as a whole like so he likes to
pay his tributes in every sense
the word the main criticism I hear about
the filmmaker of Tarantino other than
the use of the n-word is that one I was
always so we're so comfortable watching
it that's like oh my god we do all these
but the omajin versus stealing people
have defended him calling it omajin but
he's come out and said that no he just
straight-up steals the best artists
steal
yeah so even then pointing out the other
tours the other directors who pretty
much do the same thing as well shows
that that's what artists tend to do they
tend to steal make it their own and we
justify it I mean there's no there's
nothing out there that's not stolen if
it's created I mean everything's been
done so exactly that's why we always
guys he's just being honest about it
yeah I love interviews with Tarantino
hell I even loved his Golden Globe
speech would you watch his Golden Globes
you know my god it was the best thing
ever
he said he said guys guys very few
people can get away with that of ego and
self-congratulation people did he go on
to say so thank me he credited the
actors a lot for really bringing this
script to life
good for him he's entitled to it I think
he might I mean yeah very there's other
film a like Michael Bay said or
something like oh god what Tarantino
you're like oh god but yeah you will
give it to you you're pretty great
filmmaker but I love his mean interviews
like that one because it's the same
person who Robert Downey jr. walked out
on oh yeah Tito oh I am shutting your
butt down yeah there was one on the on
the red carpet where he spit on someone
he doesn't care I mean he knows who he
is he knows
what he likes he knows how he feels and
he doesn't like sugarcoat it for anybody
he's an intense guy I think it's great
he's honest he's honest he likes the
party he's wide-eyed and I was gonna
have a kid any luck he really does I
also like the music that he picks for
all of his films cuz he always picks
really like interesting a lot of it's
from old movies too which is extra
awesome it's another form of stealing of
course a lot of times he'll have the
soundtracks already in mine and then he
writes scenes do that like what Edgar
Wright did for baby driver oh yeah he
does that for very specific scenes and I
think all of his movies he that's one of
his approaches is he has a particular
song in mind it kind of rich in shows
yeah I like it reflects there you know
one of my very first real rejects videos
was a reading of Pulp Fiction by Batman
and Bane and I did the voices for it you
did both of them mm-hmm
was it just you on the screen or no just
the voiceover Kyle time for you to do a
reaction to it this is from November
23rd 2013 way before I ever did a single
video reaction okay
so tell me about these [__] Josh is
legal there right I mean you just can't
walk into a restaurant roll a joint and
start puffing away I mean they want you
to smoke in your home with certain
designated places
those are it's legal to seventh I mean
that's a right the cops in Amsterdam
don't have oh man I'm going that's all
there is to it what
little differences and you know what
they call the quarter pounder with
cheese in Paris they don't call it a
quarter pounder with cheese they
wouldn't know what the [__] a quarter
pounder is what they call it Oh Royale
with cheese what they call a Big Mac
what did he call a whopper you know what
they put on french fries in Holland
instead of ketchup there we go
why'd you stop alright guys well that
was great though thanks Kyle thank you
honest trailers thank you screen jokes
this is a great video you can subscribe
to screen junkies you can do the same
crap for us notification bells galore
follow Kyle a fan Theory Pete dawn thank
you so much buddy we are talking
recently a messages hope you kick a lot
of ass with exploring new things in life
with keeping up with the writing he
wants to write some more fanfiction I
suggest you read a fanfiction about me
and Kyle on the road we discover a dead
body but underneath the dead body is a
million dollars what do we do we buy a
dress right but yeah that's all you're
right right there one page you're done
that's great